en este vídeo vamos a estudiar cómo
determinar la acidez relativa de una
molécula viendo como su base conjugada
se estabiliza con esta idea de la
electro negatividad así que aquí
nosotros tenemos un ácido genérico un
ácido por supuesto de bronce dlouhy
verdad y el ácido de brondsted laurie es
aquel que tiene la capacidad de donar
protones entonces tenemos este ácido que
puede donar un protón y entonces el
digamos esta molécula a quedaría de esta
forma si este hidrógeno se cede o es más
bien se cede el protón entonces los
electrones que conforman este enlace van
a pasar a ser parte de la configuración
de electrones de nuestra molécula verdad
y entonces esta molécula tendría una
carga formal negativa y podríamos decir
entonces que a menos es nuestra base
conjugada entonces este es nuestro ácido
de bronx
lowry d'hebron usted lowry y esta sería
nuestra base
muy bien esta es nuestra base con jugada
ahora pensemos en la estabilidad de la
base con jugada y en realidad a lo que
vamos a llegar en este vídeo es que a
mayor estabilidad tiene esta base esto
va a implicar que nuestro ácido nuestro
ha sido que en este caso es genérico
tiene más facilidad de donar su protón y
por lo tanto se sería un ácido mucho más
fuerte entonces podemos calcular qué tan
ácido es una una molécula de este estilo
calculando su valor pk como vimos en el
vídeo anterior así que vamos a empezar a
trabajar un poco de esto de acidez con
algunas moléculas y veamos su la
estabilidad de sus bases con jugadas muy
bien entonces esta es la base con jugada
que vamos a estar analizando ok tenemos
ahí estas moléculas
ahí lo tienen tenemos el metano que ya
hemos trabajado bastante con él tenemos
este que es el amoniaco tenemos agua y
ácido fluorhídrico verdad entonces lo
que vamos a trabajar con estos es
primero chequemos cuál es su valor pk y
resulta que del metano éste resulta no
ser muy ácido su valor pecado es
aproximadamente de 48 y dijimos que el
máximo rango se se encuentra más o menos
por el 50 verdad entonces este metano
casi no es ácido por otro lado el
amoniaco nh3 cnh 3 depende es
aproximadamente de 33 su valor pk muy
bien entonces si continuamos el agua
tiene un valor de cada aproximadamente
de 16 y finalmente el valor pk del ácido
fluorhídrico es aproximadamente de 3
ahora bien si te das cuenta esto lleva a
cierta tendencia de verdad estos están
acomodados de tal suerte que si nos
movemos hacia la derecha si nos movemos
hacia la derecha vamos a encontrar que
es cada vez más ácido verdad porque
dijimos que si el valor pk es más
pequeño quiere decir que es más ácido
entonces en esta dirección es más ácido
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué ocurre
con la esto se puede realmente explicar
viendo qué pasa con sus bases con
jugadas aunque entonces veamos qué
ocurre con sus bases con jugadas y si
por ejemplo aquí este hidrógeno es el
que se libera entonces aquí tenemos
digamos el hidrógeno más más éste o el
protón más ácido entonces estos
electrones forman a ser parte de este
carbono entonces esto se vería más o
menos así tendríamos nuestro carbono
unido a sus tres hidrógenos y estos los
electrones pasan a ser parte de la
configuración de este carbono verdad
en este caso que es lo que tendríamos
tendríamos h por ejemplo aquí nos
podemos suponer que este es el protón
más ácido entonces tendríamos h n y
ahora aquí tendríamos un par de
electrones y este último hidrógeno que
ocurriría con este nuevamente pues no no
importa cuál le elegimos verdad da lo
mismo podemos elegir este y tendríamos o
más bien déjenme elegir el otro para
pintarlo bien
y vamos a elegir este entonces la
configuración que vamos a tener es la
siguiente
h unido a un oxígeno aquí están sus
electrones iniciales y los que resultan
de separar de separar este hidrógeno
verdad y finalmente nos fijamos en el
ácido fluorhídrico si separamos este
protón entonces nos quedaría el flúor
con sus 8 electrones alrededor y si nos
damos cuenta todos estos terminan con
una carga formal negativa verdad en el
carbono en el nitrógeno en el oxígeno y
en el flúor muy bien entonces ahí tienen
las cuatro bases conjugadas y el más
ácido el más ácido debe tener la müller
en la base con jugada más estable verdad
entonces notemos que tanto el carbono el
nitrógeno el oxígeno y el flúor están en
el mismo periodo de la tabla de la tabla
periódica entonces si nos movemos hacia
la derecha si nos movemos en este caso
hacia la derecha
aumenta la electro negatividad verdad y
aumenta la electro negatividad muy bien
entonces la carga negativa es digamos la
más estable en un átomo electro negativo
verdad una definición que vimos de
electro negatividad era justamente la
habilidad de un acto de aunque un átomo
para jalar electrones hacia él y esa es
una forma muy simple de pensar en la
electro negatividad y porque las cargas
negativas son las más estables en un
átomo electro negativo verdad les gustan
más los electrones que a un átomo menos
electro negativo y podemos ver esa
tendencia reflejada en nuestras bases
conjugadas y como el avión de flúor este
que tenemos aquí era el más el más bien
la más estable de las bases con jugadas
y eso hace que el ácido fluorhídrico
tenga el valor pk más bajo y por lo
tanto es el ácido más fuerte de los que
mencionamos ahora veamos dos últimos
ejemplos
los últimos ejemplos y en realidad de
estos ejemplos ya los habíamos trabajado
en el vídeo anterior verdad aquí solo
para no confundirnos
hay un puntito listo entonces con estos
últimos dos ejemplos vamos a ver qué
ocurre con su acidez muy bien
entonces en el vídeo anterior vimos que
la que el valor pk del etano era
aproximadamente de 50 que hasta dijimos
prácticamente no es un ácido verdad ni
siquiera y digamos que podemos tomar
este como el protón más masa si lo
verdad en el caso del etanol
este es el protón más ácido y dijimos
que su valor pk era aproximadamente de
16 verdad entonces también lo que
mencionamos en el vídeo anterior era que
el etanol era 10 a la 34 veces más ácido
y eso es muchísimo pero eso nuevamente
lo podemos explicar analizando quiénes
son sus bases conjugadas entonces por
ejemplo en este caso podríamos
prácticamente calcar la molécula verdad
calca mos la molécula perdón
ahí lo tienen entonces tenemos esto así
y estos dos electrones pasan a ser parte
del carbono verdad tenemos ahí estos dos
electrones porque este es el protón que
se libera ahora en este caso nuevamente
pues prácticamente copiamos la molécula
y en el caso del oxígeno vamos a tener
vamos a tener sus cuatro electrones que
ya tenía más otros dos entonces
si nos fijamos en realidad en la tabla
periódica podemos ver que el oxígeno es
mucho más estable en el sentido que
hemos estado mencionando verdad es más
estable que el carbono que en este caso
es en donde se encuentra la carga
negativa verdad tanto en el oxígeno como
en el carbono entonces como el oxígeno
es más estable que el carbono quiere
decir entonces que el valor pk va a ser
más pequeño en el caso del etanol y por
lo tanto el etanol va a ser más ácido
que el metano entonces en resumen para
para fijarnos o para más o menos ver qué
tan ácido es una molécula podemos
dibujar la base con jugada y pensar en
la estabilidad de esa base con jugada en
términos de la electro negatividad del
átomo que tiene la carga